chaleur, la prolifération des
algues bleues.
- C'est sûr que c'est plate.
On a juste un peu de vacances,
puis on tombe avec des algues.
- Avec la chaleur de ces
derniers jours, ce vacancier
était prêt pour la baignade.
Mais voilà qu'elle est interdite
sur de nombreuses plages qui
bordent la baie de Missisquoi.
C'est en raison de la présence
de ce qu'on appelle les
efflorescences de
cyanobactéries. Les micro-
organismes qui peuvent
développer des toxines.
PIERRE LEDUC, Pdt, Organisme de
bassin versant
- Cette toxine peut affecter le
foie peuvent affecter le système
nerveux peuvent causer des
irritations sur la peau. Des
gens peuvent avoir des nausées.
- L'importante présence des
algues bleu-vert est un coup dur
pour les commerçants qui
dépendent des touristes.
- Quand il y a pas d'achalandage
à la place, on coupe
les archives d'affaires de
60 à 65 %.
- Mais surtout une source
d'inquiétude pour des citoyens
qui s'alimentent en eau potable
dans la baie, comme ce résident
de Philipsburg qui vit à moins
de 100 m de l'usine de
filtration depuis des dizaines
d'années.
- de sonder un peu voir l'eau
épuisée. Samedi, l'endroit était
couvert d'une épaisse couche
d'algues.
L'odeur du lac est insuffisante
pour donner la nausée.
Malgré tout, les autorités
locales se font plus
rassurantes.
Les techniques actuelles
permettent de filtrer l'eau.
Mais ce n'est pas assez.
Ils croient que les autorités
doivent en faire plus pour
comprendre le problème des
alliés à la racine. Mais c'est
un travail de titan parce que le
réchauffement climatique
encourage la croissance des
algues.
- Ce sont des organismes qui
aiment énormément la chaleur.
- En 50 ans l'eau a déjà
augmenté de deux